chris terry and i talked about what we
felt
the last chapter of this nine film
series
should be what we felt we inherited both
you know in terms of of character also
in terms of theme uh in this trilogy in
the two prior trilogies and it was just
it felt the more we talked about it the
more inevitable it felt that this
character who was so important in the
first two trilogies uh
come back and and in some form and how
it happens and what the story is you'll
see but that was what we did and then we
told the
studio what we were going to do and they
signed off and the studio has been
amazing by the way
[Music]
uh
yes the we had all sorts of challenges
um one of them was uh having carrie
fisher in the film because she
sadly had passed away and uh realizing
we needed her in the movie we tried to
figure out the best way to do that and
we
looked at footage we had from force
awakens and realized we could take
footage
of
scenes that we had shot that we hadn't
used
and used shots
for this film by writing scenes around
her so chris and i as we came up with a
story
found pieces that we knew we could use
it was almost like doing a puzzle where
we had these certain puzzle pieces and
then we had to create puzzle pieces
around that puzzle piece to fit
and when you see the movie you'll see
that she's in the film and as a fan of
not just star wars but of
leia particularly and and carrie as a
human uh
to have her in the movie feels like a
real gift
uh well i mean there's so many
you know the
the first time you meet han solo is one
of the great moments ever
the battle on hoth is you know
unforgettable uh
and and something that i will never
forget seeing for the first time
most any scene with yoda is incredible
uh that you can think of
the shocking death of of obi-wan
um
was just the best uh i mean i i could
just literally just think of any scene
it's like open any page of the book and
it's your favorite uh page so there are
just too many to name but um
you know all of empire strikes back
looks the the photography in that film
the feeling of that movie was just so it
was so beautifully
made
um
like i said they're just there are too
many moments that i appreciate
especially now working
as a director on these films
i've i've come to see how easy they made
it look
uh when it really is not easy at all
[Music]
kevin feige needs no advice for me i
mean he's he's
doing uh obviously uh incredible work so
i cannot wait to see what what he does
and what all the filmmakers do with
kathy
it's a great question
it can be
a line of dialogue it can be a shot it
can be
costume design it could be a creature
design ship design
everything sort of goes through
this same filter which i'm sure
is maybe different for everyone or or at
least you know
various people have their own opinions
but there is something that feels like
oh that's that feels like star wars and
that doesn't feel like star wars and
it's a bit like you know when you see it
you can't
tell you can't like create a
a list of criteria and say this is what
makes something star wars this is what
makes it not star wars um
except for maybe shoes someone mentioned
that they don't have laces and that
there are no buttons i'm like well
that's probably true but in terms of of
something that feels like star wars or
not uh it's a strange
gut feeling and it's not to say that
anyone's right but it's like everyone
has their own sense of what that is
[Music]
i'm definitely you know
curious what people think and i'm aware
of you know what
fans are generally thinking and and
saying though i'm sure i'm missing
a huge amount at all times but i you
know i'm i'd like to think i'm generally
aware
you take that into consideration just
the way you take into consideration
things that you know
friends of yours say and people you
trust you know family who are honest
about what's going on articles are being
written what what critics might say you
know all of it is sort of a and there's
a lot of noise and a lot of opinions i
mean there are more opinions somehow
there are more opinions than people i
don't know how that happens but um
ultimately i think it's really important
you get a sense of it
but it's very
dangerous i think to take any of that
stuff
too seriously or to pay too much
attention to any of it
because
anyone who has an opinion there's
someone else who has the opposite
opinion
and often they're
both
loud and they're both right
and so if you try to like please any one
group
you're immediately upsetting someone
else so i think the best thing the only
thing you can do is say
i respect those people i respect those
opinions they're all correct
and here's my opinion and then make your
movie
well you know everyone should you know
who sees the film will have their own
experience of it and their own sense of
it but
i will say that our ambition in making
it was to tell a story where you'd feel
better when you leave the theater than
when you get there and i hope that's
what happens for people